I hope everybody had a good Memorial Day
long weekend if you had one uh I
actually had an anti-semitic incident
over the weekend someone hurling
anti-semitic abuse at me on the street I
will tell you that story later in the
show but I also came back from the break
to realize that the treasonous and
seditious tentacles of the Trump
Administration continue to grow and
spread Donald Trump's indicted and
pardoned former National Security
adviser Michael Flynn has been caught on
video saying that a coup like what
happened in Myanmar should happen in the
United States presumably against the Joe
Biden Administration now this is not
some random you know Q Anon Shaman
wearing a weird hat saying it this is a
former National Security advisor to the
president of the United States
Flynn said this Sunday night during a q
a session at a conference called the for
God and Country Patriot Roundup in
Dallas Texas there is a little detail
here that is just perfect which is that
the person asking Flynn the question
doesn't even know that it's Myanmar
instead he says minamar like every
detail is harebrained the focus is
Flynn's answer of course but even the
question is just you couldn't write this
stuff
simple Marine I want to know why what
happened in minamar can't happen here
foreign
[Applause]
it should happen here says a former
National Security adviser to a president
of the United States what happened in
Myanmar or minamar as he said a coup in
Myanmar started on the morning of
February 1st this year
when democratically elected members of
the country's ruling party the national
league for democracy were thrown out
they were deposed by the tatmada
myanmar's military which then uh vested
power in a stratocracy and the country's
military executed a morning raid they
detained the elected leader aung sung
tsuki and other political figures the
military said what we did is write
because there was voter fraud allegation
in the Myanmar November election so the
link is of course the analogy they claim
exists with voter fraud stealing the
election from Donald Trump in our
November of 2020 election which they
therefore used to justify what Michael
Flynn says there should be a coup
and Joe Biden should be deposed should
be forcibly removed from the White House
now remember that these are the very
people the loudest ones screaming about
how they are patriots they have no
actual respect for the Constitution
however they are the loudest ones
screaming about we are for the rule of
law it must be law and order but they
have no respect for the rule of law they
are attacking us from within
now as a practical question is this
beyond the limits of free speech because
it's an incitement to violence a retired
General that is so clearly a traitor and
there is a key difference here between
the modern left and the modern right and
it's important to talk about and when
when there are similar when you can't
tell the difference between left and
right we pointed out
but we're left and right couldn't be
more different we also point that out
when the people I vote for lose an
election I don't like it but I don't say
let's overthrow the government even when
for years the Russia probe looked at
whether Donald Trump was helped by a
foreign power in 2016. all of that stuff
the left wasn't saying let's do a
violent Insurrection to remove Donald
Trump and by the way as far as Flynn
goes who is even paying Michael Flynn
now is he does he have a pension from
the military if so shouldn't this lead
to you losing your pension is he getting
paid for these one-off appearances is
someone funding what he's doing and who
even would want to do that at this point
in time not the best people that's for
sure
and this is why down playing January 6th
is so dangerous if you downplay the
importance of January 6th it makes
escalation more likely it welcomes the
escalation and when you hear a statement
like this from Michael Flynn it shows
that Republicans have truly learned
nothing from the January 6th Trump riots
not and not only that it's actually an
escalation of rhetoric and it's hard to
know uh what what what the the right
really sees as the next step here with
this stuff and in a sense what
Republicans have learned from January 6
so far because you know look look at
what's taking place so far
they've learned that nobody's really
going to stop them and it's not even
clear there will be consequences if they
do another version of January 6th so now
the trend that we're seeing is those who
have claimed for years to be about Law
and Order and those who for years have
pointed fingers at antifa and black
lives matter and eco-terrorists and the
violent left or whatever the case may be
those are the people who now are
regularly calling for violence over the
last few weeks and I want to take a
moment and look at that Trend now with
this additional example of Trump's
former National Security adviser Michael
Flynn one of our sponsors today is nebia
the creator of the world's most
Innovative shower head it uses only
about half the water that other shower
heads do saving you money helping the
environment but it's actually a lot more
powerful than other shower heads on the
market it has twice the coverage of
other shower heads the water sprays with
a ton of pressure I've been using it in
my bathroom at home I love it only took
a few minutes to set up really easy and
it's been a totally different experience
than any other shower head I've used I
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now because of how powerful it
is it only takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off so I was actually
amazed that it's only using about half
as much water nebia also offers a number
of shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match perfectly with the
design of the shower head the shower
head starts at just 199 and you'll get
10 percent off all nevia products when
you go to nebby dot com slash Pacman and
use the coupon code Pacman the link is
right underneath this video